president Trump eased into the holiday
weekend making its way to Florida and
onto the golf course the president has
no public events on a schedule for today
but the drama from Washington follows
him for more changes in his
administration down to mounting
questions about his plans to handle the
war in Syria we jayjay is in West Palm
Beach with the president we show good
morning
Reno good morning president Trump is
reassessing America's role in Syria just
yesterday freezing 200 million dollars
in funds for recovery efforts it does
not impact the Defense Department's
operations but the president has made
clear he wants other countries to
contribute more to recovery efforts
specifically Saudi Arabia we're going to
be coming out of there real soon just
hours after the president made that
comment a roadside bomb went off in
northern Syria killing an American
servicemember let the other people take
care of it now the declaration from
President Trump differs from the current
US policy on Syria to remain engaged and
gradually shift from a military led
mission to a diplomatic one the State
Department has not clarified a timeline
since the president's remarks I have not
seen the president's comments myself but
I can say that as a general matter this
administration looks to other countries
to help out roughly 2,000 US troops
remain on the ground right now managing
them is challenging in part because the
positions of Secretary of State and
national security adviser have not been
officially filled since the president
fired Rex Tillerson and HR McMaster this
week the staff shakeups continued
communications director Hope Hicks
wrapped her last day and the president
swapped out the Secretary of Veterans
Affairs
David Chokin out White House dr. Ronnie
Jackson in I wasn't happy with the speed
with which our veterans were taken care
of
now another cabinet member faces more
scrutiny for his financial decisions EPA
Administrator Scott Pruitt reportedly
paid 50
a night to stay in a private DC condo
linked to a prominent energy lobbyist
whose firm represents big gas companies
Pruitt was already under fire for
spending more than $120,000 on a work
trip to Italy last summer the EPA issued
a statement to say
Pruitt's leasing agreement does not
violate any federal regulations on
ethics regarding gifts because he paid
market value $1,500 a month for a
one-bedroom apartment but Anthony Pruitt
reportedly only paid for the nights he
stayed in the condo and the market value
for a hotel room in DC is well more than
$50 a night we judge hang in West Palm
Beach thanks